There's really no way around some arguments. Maybe arguments just want to happen. One of the producers of our radio show, This American Life , was at this conference recently, and this guy named Eric Molinsky told her about this strangely and unexpectedly fierce argument that he had gotten into with a good friend of his. It was his cousin in fact. And the whole thing started with no warning at all. Like he told Nancy, they were happily chatting away in a nice warm cafe.
有些争论真的是没法避免的。也许争论就是会自然发生。我们广播节目《美国生活》的一位制作人最近参加了这次会议，一个叫埃里克·莫林斯基的人告诉她，他和他的一位好友之间发生了一场奇怪且意想不到的激烈争论。事实上，那个人是他的表亲。整个事情毫无征兆地就开始了。就像他告诉南希的那样，他们当时正惬意地坐在一家温暖舒适的咖啡馆里聊天。
Everything was like comfort food, comfort seats and we were so comfortable--.
一切都像舒适的食物、舒适的座椅，我们感到如此自在——
I'm getting tense already just hearing about it.
光是听着这件事，我就已经感到紧张了。
We were so comfortable. It was one of those things where you actually could hardly touch the table. You actually had to sit up in your giant lounge chair to get the soup on the little table.
我们当时太舒服了。那种感觉就像是坐在那儿几乎都碰不到桌子。你必须坐在巨大的休闲椅上直起腰来，才能把汤放到小桌子上。
The comfy soup.
舒适的汤。
The comfy soup, yeah. So we were talking along, and I remember I-- somehow I brought this up, about corporate tax loopholes. And then she was like, first she said, well, let me play the devil's advocate here. Not that I'm defending corporations, but don't you think that if you're going to make them pay taxes, they're just going to pick up and leave and go to another state? And she kept saying, not that I'm defending corporations.
舒适的汤，对。我们聊着聊着，我记得我——不知怎么就提起了企业税漏洞的话题。然后她说，她先是说，好吧，让我来唱个反调吧。并不是我在为大公司辩护，但你不觉得如果你强迫它们缴税，它们就会直接拍拍屁股走人，去别的州吗？她不停地说，我不是在为大公司辩护。
And we kind of got deeper and deeper into this, and she sort of eventually stopped apologizing for defending corporations and really was going after this idea that it was just irresponsible. It was typical kind of liberal--.
我们越聊越深，她最后甚至不再为自己辩护大公司而道歉，而是真正开始攻击这种想法，认为那是不负责任的。这是一种典型的自由派……
Knee jerk.
膝跳反射。
Anti-business.
反商。
Exactly And this is the way the world works. This is the way the world goes around. Money, money, money. I ended up being grandstanding. This goes into the highways, this goes into health care for everybody.
没错。这就是世界运转的方式。这就是世界的运行之道。金钱，金钱，金钱。我最后开始高谈阔论。税收会投入到公路建设中，会投入到全民医疗保健中。
And in the middle of this tirade, in the back of his mind, Eric was thinking, why are we getting so heated up over this, both of us? And then, something occurred to Eric.
就在他滔滔不绝的时候，埃里克的脑海里闪过一个念头：我们两个为什么为了这个争得面红耳赤？然后，埃里克突然想到了一件事。
I think the way that I said it was, you know, I have to admit, I really don't know a lot about this issue. Or I didn't really know a lot about it until my ex-girlfriend explained it to me.
我想我是这么说的，你知道，我不得不承认，在这个问题上我确实了解不多。或者说，直到我前女友向我解释之前，我并不怎么了解。
When you said that, what did your cousin say?
当你这么说的时候，你表亲怎么回答？
Well, she paused. And she said, well, to be honest, I didn't really know a lot about this issue either. But I had an ex-boyfriend who educated me on it.
嗯，她停顿了一下。她说，老实说，我对此了解也不多。但我有个前男友曾给我科普过。
Eric's ex-girlfriend was a political activist with a special focus on corporate tax loopholes. His cousin Mara's ex-boyfriend worked in hedge funds.
埃里克的前女友是一位专注于企业税漏洞的政治活动家。他表亲玛拉的前男友在对冲基金工作。
And so we just stopped for a second. And it was interesting, because that was the end of the argument and that's when I said to her, I think that my ex-girlfriend just got into a huge, 20-minute argument with your ex-boyfriend.
于是我们停顿了一会儿。这很有趣，因为那就是争论的终点，当时我对她说，我想我前女友刚刚和你前男友进行了一场长达二十分钟的激烈争论。
You know when you fall in love with somebody, it's like they have an open path straight to your heart. And without you even realizing it, other things can just ride in on that path-- political ideas, favorite bands, favorite writers, pet peeves. And where those things are concerned, you basically just become the person you love. You're like their proxy. In my own life, my own opinions about television are so thoroughly shaped by my wife's opinions that a coworker recently told me that sometimes she wished that she could just skip the middleman and talk straight to my wife.
你知道，当你爱上一个人时，就像他们通向你的内心有一条畅通无阻的路。在你还没意识到的时候，其他东西——政治观点、最喜欢的乐队、最喜欢的作家、讨厌的小习惯——都会顺着那条路涌入。在这些方面，你基本上就成了你所爱的那个人。你就像他们的代理人。在我自己的生活中，我对电视的看法深受我妻子的影响，以至于我的一位同事最近跟我说，她有时希望可以直接跳过中间人，直接跟我妻子谈。
But I think that we don't just become proxies for the people that we love. It happens with friends. It happens in business settings. It happens in politics. And when it happens, things can get very confusing. When you really step in for somebody else, substitute yourself for somebody else, it can be hard to tell if you're doing the right thing at all. If you're doing what they would want or what you want.
但我认为，我们不仅仅是所爱之人的代理人。这种情况也会发生在朋友之间。发生在商业环境中。发生在政治领域。当这种情况发生时，事情可能会变得非常混乱。当你真正代替某人行事，以某人作为替身时，你很难判断自己做得是否完全正确。你是做了他们想做的事，还是你真正想做的事。
Well, from Chicago Public Radio, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, By Proxy, stories of people turning into proxies for other people, sometimes by choice, sometimes they just find that it's happened to them without them even noticing. Act one of our show today, I'm The Decider. What do you do when a friend asks you to make a decision that she probably should be making for herself? Well, Davy Rothbart found himself in that very position. Act two, Killing The Messengers, what it's like to be the proxy for the least popular guys in town, when the town is Mosul and the guys are the US Army. Act three, Redemption By Proxy, a teenage girl and a message from beyond the grave. Stay with us.
这里是来自芝加哥公共广播电台的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“代理人”，讲述人们成为他人代理人的故事，有时是出于选择，有时是发现自己还没意识到就发生了。今天节目的第一幕是“决策者”。当朋友让你做一个她本应自己决定的决定时，你该怎么办？戴维·罗斯巴特就发现自己处于这种境地。第二幕“杀死信使”，讲述成为城里最不受欢迎的人的代理人是什么感觉，当那个城市是摩苏尔，而这些人是美军时。第三幕“代理救赎”，一位少女和来自坟墓后的信息。请留下来。
Act one, I'm The Decider. There are all kinds of situations where we step in as reluctant proxies. As a favor for friends or family, taking over some chore they don't want to do, taking their kids or their pets off their hands for a while. Doing something because it's the right thing to do and nobody else is stepping in. That's what happened to Davy Rothbart, more or less.
第一幕，我是决策者。在各种情况下，我们都会成为不情愿的代理人。作为对朋友或家人的帮忙，接手一些他们不想做的杂务，或者暂时帮他们照看孩子或宠物。做这些事是因为这是正确的事，而其他人又没去帮忙。这多多少少就是戴维·罗斯巴特所经历的事情。
So Cassandra is this childhood friend of mine who moved away when she was maybe 13 to Chicago, then to California, then Pensacola, Florida. I think she had kind of a tough go of things growing up. She never really knew her dad, and her and her mom and brother kept moving around a ton. A couple times she called me crying when she had to pull up stakes again. We wrote a lot of letters back and forth, and when we were 20, we traveled around Eastern Europe together, just as friends.
卡桑德拉是我儿时的朋友，她在13岁左右搬走了，先去了芝加哥，然后是加州，接着是佛罗里达州的彭萨科拉。我想她成长过程中过得挺艰辛的。她从没真正认识她的父亲，她和母亲、哥哥一直搬来搬去。有好几次她打电话给我，哭诉自己又要被迫搬家。我们写了很多信，当我们20岁时，我们作为朋友一起去东欧旅游。
Every couple of years since, she'll surface in my life by way of a middle of the night phone call. She'll be in the midst of a crisis and desperate for my advice. Maybe about problems at her work, or  with school, or with a boyfriend, her little brother in trouble with the law. She'll say things to me like, you're so sensible. You understand how things work. You're so smart about things. Not just smart, but wise. It's kind of hard to resist.
从那以后，每隔几年她就会在我的生活中出现，通常是半夜的一通电话。她会处于危机之中，急切地寻求我的建议。可能是关于工作、学校的问题，或者是男朋友的问题，还有她弟弟惹上的官司。她会对我撒娇说，你太理智了。你明白事情是怎么运作的。你对这些事情太聪明了。不仅仅是聪明，而是睿智。这很难拒绝。
So after she calls me with a problem, for a week or so we talk every day, just going through it all. And by then, we've figured out a good approach. Say she's got a manager at work who's overly flirtatious, making her uncomfortable. I kind of ask her a bunch of questions. What's he doing exactly? How often? Have other people witnessed his behavior? Who's his supervisor? After talking a bunch, we make a plan for some kind of decisive action. She feels a whole lot better, and I, in turn, feel sensible, knowledgeable and smart. Not just smart, but wise.
所以每当她打电话求助，我们就会连续一周每天通话，把事情梳理一遍。到那时，我们已经想出了一个好办法。比方说，如果她工作中有个经理过分献殷勤，让她感到不舒服。我会问她一堆问题。他具体做了什么？多久一次？有没有其他人看到他的行为？谁是他的主管？谈完后，我们制定了一个果断行动的计划。她感觉好多了，而我也因此感到自己很理智、博学、聪明。不仅仅是聪明，是睿智。
Then a few years ago she called me, freaking out. She had a new kind of crisis, not like anything I had ever dealt with before. She was pregnant, almost three months pregnant. The dad was her sometimes boyfriend, a hippie wanderer type named Rainbow Bear. She was living in Santa Barbara, she said, without any close friends around, no one to really turn to, and she was really upset and confused, torn up about whether she should have this baby or not. Rainbow Bear wasn't involved. She said to me, tell me what to do and I'll do it.
然后几年前，她打电话给我，惊慌失措。她遇到了一个新的危机，与我之前处理过的任何事情都不一样。她怀孕了，快三个月了。孩子父亲是她断断续续的男友，一个名叫彩虹熊的嬉皮流浪汉。她说她住在圣巴巴拉，身边没有亲密朋友，没人可以依靠，她非常难过和困惑，纠结于是否要留下这个孩子。彩虹熊没参与这件事。她对我说，告诉我该怎么做，我就怎么做。
So I did pretty much what any sensible and smart person would do in that situation. I told her I couldn't make the decision for her, but that I would do everything I could to equip her with as much information as possible, so that she'd be able to decide what to do on her own. Then I got to work. I knew one friend who'd had an abortion and had always been haunted by it, and another friend who'd had an abortion and, while sad about it of course, really believed it had been the right thing to do. I also found a woman who'd given her baby up for adoption, and another who'd kept her baby and was a single mom.
所以我做了任何一个理智聪明的人在这种情况下会做的事。我告诉她，我不能替她做决定，但我会尽我所能为她提供尽可能多的信息，这样她就能自己决定做什么。然后我开始行动。我认识一个曾经堕胎并一直为此感到内疚的朋友，还有另一个堕胎后虽然难过但认为那是正确选择的朋友。我还找到了一位把孩子送去领养的女性，以及另一位单身抚养孩子的母亲。
I got them all to agree to talk to Cassandra, but she was really shy, and too upset to reach out to strangers. Those are your friends, not mine, she said, I'll feel weird calling them. So OK, I changed my plan, and talked at great length to each of these women myself, then relayed their stories to Cassandra, careful to present them in a balanced way, so it wouldn't seem like I was favoring one option over another.
我让他们都同意和卡桑德拉谈谈，但她很害羞，太难过了，不敢接触陌生人。她说，那是你的朋友，不是我的，给他们打电话我会觉得奇怪。好吧，我改变了计划，自己和这些女性详细交谈，然后把她们的故事转述给卡桑德拉，尽量保持平衡，这样看起来就不会像我在偏袒任何一种选择。
I'd even gone so far as so talk to a couple of friends in med school to gauge the medical risks of a later first term abortion. Relatively safe, it turns out. At the end of all this, Cassandra was only more confused and overwhelmed. Please, she begged me, tell me what you think I should do. And that's where I should have said, look, nobody can tell you what to do in this situation. Of course this is agonizing, but only you can know what path to take. Whatever you choose, that will be the right decision. But that's not what I said.
我甚至去咨询了几个医学院的朋友，评估了第一次妊娠晚期流产的医疗风险。事实证明，相对安全。这一切结束后，卡桑德拉更加困惑和不知所措。求你了，她恳求我，告诉我你觉得我该怎么做。这就是我本该说“看，没人能在这个情况下告诉你该怎么做。这当然很痛苦，但只有你能决定走哪条路。无论你选择什么，那都是正确的决定”的时候。但那不是我说的。
Cassandra was barely getting by on her own as a cashier at a health food store. No medical insurance, shady roommates, a shaky lease, a boyfriend named Rainbow Bear. Cassandra, I said, I know being a mother appeals to you but you're still so young. Maybe this isn't the right time. Down the road you'll have the chance to have a baby with a guy who's going to be there to raise the child with you. It's just going to be so hard on your own. I think you should wait. I think you should wait. Sort of a pleasant euphemism for kill the fetus.
卡桑德拉靠在健康食品店当收银员勉强维持生计。没有医疗保险，室友不可靠，租约也不稳定，还有个叫彩虹熊的男友。我说，卡桑德拉，我知道你很想当母亲，但你还太年轻。也许现在不是时候。以后你还有机会和一个愿意和你一起抚养孩子的男人有个孩子。你自己一个人会太辛苦的。我认为你应该等等。我认为你应该等等。这算是一种杀死胎体的委婉说法。
Cassandra sounded sad but she said I was right, and that now she knew what to do. She kept thanking me for being such a kind and generous friend. We talked maybe once more the next day, and then she disappeared again. For months afterwards, I felt weird about what I'd done. I did think it was probably for the best, but what if something went wrong and she was never able to have children again? Or what if she never found the right guy and this had been her one chance to be a mother? I think it would have felt equally weird if I'd told her to have the baby too. I just felt like I shouldn't have been the one to decide.
卡桑德拉听起来很悲伤，但她说我是对的，现在她知道该怎么做了。她不停地感谢我作为一个如此善良慷慨的朋友。第二天我们可能又谈了一次，然后她又消失了。接下来的几个月里，我对自己的所作所为感到不安。我认为这可能是最好的结果，但如果出了什么差错，她以后再也不能生孩子了怎么办？或者如果她再也没遇到对的人，而这曾是她成为母亲的唯一机会呢？我想如果我当时劝她留下孩子，感觉也会同样奇怪。我只是觉得我不该是那个做决定的人。
Three years later, I'm living in Chicago and I get a call. It's Cassandra. She's in the Chicago suburbs staying with her grandfather. She invites me out to visitor her and we agree to meet the next day at the playground across from her grandfather's house. I pull up, hop out of my car, and there's Cassandra, waving to me from beside the swing set. Then I see, tearing through the grass toward me, a little blond, two year old boy. It's Cassandra's son of course. She had the baby after all, and he's got the same name as my favorite basketball player in the world, Isaiah, like Isaiah Thomas. Davy, meet Isaiah Bear.
三年后，我住在芝加哥，接到了一个电话。是卡桑德拉。她正住在芝加哥郊区的爷爷家。她邀请我去探望她，我们约定第二天在爷爷家对面的游乐场见面。我把车停下跳出来，卡桑德拉正站在秋千旁向我招手。然后我看到一个金发两岁小男孩正飞奔向我。那是卡桑德拉的儿子。她最终还是生下了孩子，而且他的名字和我最喜欢的篮球运动员 Isaiah 一样，像以赛亚·托马斯。戴维，见见 Isaiah Bear。
My eyes got all watery. And Isaiah, he's like the most incredible, joyous, dazzlingly intelligent two year old boy I've ever met in my life. I swear this is true. That night, we brought him to my friend Nicole's house. I was couch surfing at her place at the time. And when we introduced him to 12 people in a circle, he went right back around and knew every single person's name. Incredible. At the same time, as amazing as Isaiah was, Cassandra was struggling. Rainbow bear had rumbled off and she'd been bouncing from town to town, first staying with his parents, then an old boyfriend or two, and now her grandfather. But that was a bad situation too. She had to get out of there.
我的眼眶湿润了。Isaiah 是我这辈子见过最不可思议、最快乐、最聪明伶俐的两岁男孩。我发誓这是真的。那天晚上，我们把他带到我朋友妮可家。当时我正寄住在她那儿。当我们把他介绍给围成一圈的12个人时，他绕了一圈，叫出了每个人的名字。太神奇了。同时，尽管 Isaiah 很棒，但卡桑德拉生活得很挣扎。彩虹熊跑了，她一直在各个城镇间辗转，先是住在男友父母家，然后是那一两个前男友家，现在是她爷爷家。但这情况也很糟。她必须离开那里。
And here I was. I felt pretty guilty for having pressed Cassandra to have an abortion. Somehow I thought, if I could help his path toward a good life, I could make up for that little part where I'd suggested he be exterminated. So I jumped back in again. I took over. And I came up with a plan. I'd move back home to my folks' house in Michigan for a little while. I'd bring Cassandra and Isaiah to live with us for a couple of months in Ann Arbor. And Cassandra said that's what she wanted. Stay with my folks, get a job, work and save money, then move into her own place and raise her son.
而我出现在这里。因为曾催促卡桑德拉堕胎，我感到非常内疚。不知怎么的，我想，如果我能帮助他走上一条好的人生道路，我就能弥补之前我建议把他抹杀掉的那一小部分。所以我又插手了。我接管了这件事。我提出了一个计划。我会回密歇根老家住上一阵子。我会带卡桑德拉和 Isaiah 来安娜堡和我们住上几个月。卡桑德拉说这就是她想要的。和我的家人们住在一起，找份工作，工作并攒钱，然后搬出去自己住，抚养她的儿子。
I was really excited about the whole thing. I truly wanted to help Cassandra, you know? She'd been a lifelong friend. And I also liked the idea of being altruistic. And the idea that this other girl I was chasing after at the time might see me as altruistic. And it occurred to me that living with Cassandra and Isaiah would be kind of like having my own kid. At the basketball court where I'd played ball in Chicago, there was this one guy who always brought his two kids with him, like two and four years old. Between games, he'd mess around with them for a couple of minutes, or shout at them from wandering too far away. I liked the idea of showing up at the court in Ann Arbor with Isaiah, and being able to cuff him, roughhouse with him and teach him how to shoot. Being a dad, or acting as a dad, makes you feel more like a man. Makes you seem a little more tough and rugged.
我对这一切感到非常兴奋。我真心想帮助卡桑德拉，你知道吗？她是我的多年好友。我也喜欢这种利他主义的感觉。而且我还想到，当时我在追求的另一个女孩可能会认为我很无私。我脑子里闪过一个念头，和卡桑德拉及 Isaiah 住在一起，就像拥有了自己的孩子一样。在芝加哥打球的球场上，有一个人总是带着他两岁和四岁的孩子一起去。比赛间隙，他会和他们玩一会儿，或者在他们跑远时喊他们回来。我喜欢在安娜堡的球场上带着 Isaiah 出现，能够拍拍他、和他嬉闹、教他投篮的样子。当父亲，或者扮演父亲的角色，会让你感觉更有男子气概。让你看起来更有韧性。
Having Cassandra and Isaiah in Ann Arbor was great. My mom got a little kiddy pool for the backyard, and Sandra and Isaiah spent all afternoon and evening back there. Cassandra made soup and all kinds of complicated vegan foods in the kitchen and washed her clothes with a hose and hung them up to dry on the old, rusty playground equipment out back. We had a basketball hoop in our driveway, and me and my friends started showing young Isaiah how to shoot. We called him Zeke, after Isaiah Thomas' nickname. And the kid, Zeke, had the sunniest disposition, and he was a natural athlete.
让卡桑德拉和 Isaiah 在安娜堡住着感觉很棒。我妈在后院买了个小充气泳池，桑德拉和 Isaiah 整下午整晚上都在那儿玩。卡桑德拉在厨房里煮汤，做各种复杂的素食，用软管洗衣服，然后把它们晾在后面生锈的旧游乐设施上。我们的车道上有一个篮球架，我和朋友们开始教小 Isaiah 投篮。我们叫他 Zeke，取自以赛亚·托马斯的绰号。这孩子，Zeke，性格非常开朗，还是个天生的运动员。
I started in pretty quickly trying to find Sandra a job. Between me, my friends, and my parents, we found a few solid leads, solid enough that all she had to do was show up for an interview and the job would be hers. These weren't dream jobs, but they were decent paying jobs, like working the register at a Birkenstock store or taking phone orders at Bell's Pizza. But every time we had an interview set up for Sandra, she managed to miss it. She got lost on her way there or Isaiah was nursing and she couldn't leave him right then, those kinds of things. Finally, one day I drove her to an interview. Though she had her own car, I just wanted to make sure she actually went to it.
我很快就开始着手帮桑德拉找工作。我和朋友、父母合力，找到了一些不错的机会，只要她去面试就能录用。这些不是什么梦幻职位，但工资还算体面，比如在勃肯鞋店收银或在必胜客接订单。但每次我们给她安排好面试，她总能错过。她在路上迷路了，或者 Isaiah 正在喂奶她走不开，诸如此类的理由。最后，有一天我开车送她去面试。虽然她自己有车，但我只想确保她真的去了。
She got the job, a receptionist at a new agey type salon. They asked her to start work the next morning. I drew a careful map with clear directions so she'd have no trouble finding the place and even set her alarm clock to wake her in plenty of time to get to work. My plan was for me and my dad to split the day looking after Zeke, and then on days we weren't around, Zeke could go to daycare. But the next morning, I wake up and Cassandra's just laying in bed, playing with Zeke. I charged into the room. Oh my God, you're two hours late for work, and it's your first day. And she's just like, oh, I decided not to go.
她得到了那份工作，在一家新时代风格的沙龙做前台。他们让她第二天早上上班。我画了一张详细的地图，标明路线，这样她就不会迷路，甚至还给她定好了闹钟，保证她能准时醒来。我的计划是我和我爸轮流看 Zeke，我们不在的时候，Zeke 可以去托儿所。但第二天早上，我醒来发现卡桑德拉还躺在床上跟 Zeke 玩。我冲进房间，“天哪，你迟到两个小时了，还是第一天！”而她却说，“哦，我决定不去了。”
If you knew Cassandra, you'd be shocked when I told you that she never smoked pot because she just had that total, glassy, dreamlike air to her, completely unperturbed by real world situations. In a lot of ways, she was like a child, which became so frustrating. Cassandra kept putting all of her decisions in my hands, but then she wasn't actually doing any of the things I was telling her to do. And I finally realized, things that were easy for me, like showing up for work on time, showing up at all, were not easy for her. It was clear, she wasn't going to get a job.
如果你了解卡桑德拉，你会很惊讶。她从不吸毒，因为她总有一种完全空灵、梦幻般的气质，对现实世界的处境完全无动于衷。在很多方面，她就像个孩子，这让人非常沮丧。卡桑德拉不断把所有决定权交到我手上，但实际上却没做任何我告诉她要做的事。我终于意识到，对我来说容易的事，比如准时上班，甚至根本就是去上班，对她来说一点都不容易。很明显，她不可能去工作的。
And I don't want to be too critical. Taking care of her two year old, she was exhausted all the time. And really, I began to understand just how difficult it would be to raise a kid on your own. I mean, that stuff is relentless when you have two parents. But all alone, it's brutal. Even for me, the allure of playing dad began to wane. I was stuck babysitting a lot. When I tried to take Zeke with me to the schoolyard where I always played basketball, he didn't understand that he couldn't come out on the court when the grownups were playing, and I had to leave the game and take him home. And most days, I'd be at home, trying to get some kind of important work done on the computer, and play Hungry Hungry Hippo at the same time.
我不想太苛刻。照顾她两岁的孩子让她精疲力尽。说实话，我开始明白独自抚养一个孩子有多困难。我是说，有两个父母的情况下这种事都是无穷无尽的。但独自一人，那简直是残酷。连我也开始对扮演父亲的角色感到厌倦了。我被困在看孩子这件事上。当我试图带 Zeke 去我常打球的操场时，他不明白大人们在比赛时他不能上场，我不得不中止比赛带他回家。大部分日子，我都在家，试图在电脑上做些重要的工作，同时还要玩“饥饿河马”游戏。
Suddenly, I felt desperately like I needed an out. My parents recognized that Cassandra had no intention of finding her own housing and they were ready to have their house back and I was ready to have my life back. My stab at playing dad revealed itself for what it was all along-- a theme park ride, a novelty, a selfish gift. So naturally, I hatched a new, even more ill-conceived plan, and tried to hook Cassandra up with my friend Brandy, so he could take her off my hands.
突然，我迫切需要找个出口。我父母也意识到卡桑德拉根本没打算找自己的住房，他们准备把房子要回来，我也准备要回自己的生活。我扮演父亲的尝试最终显现出它的本质——一个主题公园游乐设施，一种新奇玩意，一份自私的礼物。所以很自然地，我又制定了一个更不靠谱的计划，试图把我朋友布兰迪介绍给卡桑德拉，好让他接手。
I knew Brandy was into Cassandra, and he was great with Isaiah, so I kept making plans for all of us to hang out together, then ducking out at the last minute. Randy took over all the dad responsibilities I'd felt saddled with, and Cassandra enjoyed Brandy's kindness and attention. There was actually a momentary romantic spark, and I saw everything unspooling beautifully. But Randy was living at home with his own mom, and they were barely making ends meet as it was. Randy's mom quashed everything really quick. There's no way they're moving in here with us. One of the lowest moments of this whole strange saga was when Cassandra said to me one day-- not angrily, just plainly-- if you want me to leave, I'll leave. You don't have to try and peddle me off on your friends.
我知道布兰迪对卡桑德拉有好感，而且他和 Isaiah 相处得很好，所以我不断计划让我们四个人一起玩，然后最后一刻借故开溜。布兰迪接手了我感到负荷的所有父亲责任，卡桑德拉也享受着布兰迪的善意和关注。那一刻确实产生了一丝浪漫火花，我看到一切都在美好地展开。但布兰迪当时和自己的母亲住在一起，他们自己都入不敷出。布兰迪的母亲很快就把一切都扼杀在摇篮里。“他们不可能和我们搬到一起住。”整个怪异事件中最卑微的时刻之一是有一天卡桑德拉对我说——不是生气，只是平淡地——“如果你想让我走，我就走。你不必非得把我推销给你的朋友。”
There's a TV show from the '80s that I saw only a handful of times, but always really loved, called Quantum Leap . Remember that? Each week's episode would revolve around a different person caught up in a complicated and difficult situation that they couldn't fix. And the star of the show, Scott Bakula, would actually be zapped into that person's body, become that person, and he would make things right. It's one thing to get involved in other people's problems and do your best to help them. But man, it'd be a whole other thing if you could actually inhabit their body and fix everything up yourself. Then you could really help some people.
80年代有个电视节目我只看过几次，但一直很喜欢，叫《时空怪客》。还记得吗？每一集的情节都围绕着一个陷入困境且无法解决问题的不同人。而剧中的主角斯科特·巴库拉会神奇地进入那个人的身体，成为那个人，然后把事情变好。卷入别人的问题并尽力帮助他们是一回事。但天哪，如果能真正进入他们的身体并亲自解决一切，那是完全不同的另一回事。那样你才能真正帮助别人。
I'm sure in the end, it's not the best way to do it. At the very least, it's kind of a bullying way to look at other people's problems. But I guess that's me, wanting the ball in my hands, wanting to run the show.
我肯定最终这不是最好的办法。至少，这是一种对他人的问题指手画脚的方式。但我猜这就是我，想要把球掌握在自己手中，想要掌控全局。
Not long after Cassandra told me I didn't need to peddle her onto my friends, she decided that she and Zeke would pack up and leave town. She had been talking to Zeke's dad, Rainbow Bear, on the phone, and they were going to try to get back together. Rainbow had moved to Hawaii, and Sandra and Isaiah were headed there to meet up with him. It was one of those things where it seemed clearly kind of sad and hopeless, and at the same time, I didn't want to talk her out of it, because it meant they'd be gone and I could resume my own directionless life.
在卡桑德拉告诉我不需要把她推销给朋友后不久，她决定带着 Zeke 搬走。她一直在电话里和 Zeke 的父亲彩虹熊聊天，他们打算重归于好。彩虹熊搬到了夏威夷，桑德拉和 Isaiah 准备去那儿找他。那看起来显然有点悲伤且绝望，同时，我不想劝阻她，因为这意味着他们会离开，而我可以恢复我原本漫无目的的生活。
Cassandra was nothing but sweet and totally appreciative of what me and my family had done for her. But I felt miserable. I worked with little Zeke one last afternoon on his perimeter shooting, then watched him and Cassandra drive away. And then I cried.
卡桑德拉对我及我的家人所做的一切充满了甜蜜和感激。但我感觉糟透了。那天下午我最后一次教小 Zeke 练习外线投篮，然后看着他和卡桑德拉开车离开。那一刻我哭了。
Davy Rothbart in Ann Arbor. His book of stories is The Lone Surfer of Montana, Kansas. He's also the creator of Found Magazine , which is at foundmagazine.com.
以上是安娜堡的戴维·罗斯巴特。他的故事集是《蒙大拿州堪萨斯州的独行冲浪者》。他也是《发现》杂志的创始人，网址是 foundmagazine.com。
[MUSIC - "I DON'T KNOW WHAT I CAN SAVE YOU FROM" BY KINGS OF CONVENIENCE]
[音乐 - “我不知道我能救你于何处” - 现实之王]
Coming up, so your country's been occupied by a foreign army, and you work for that army. Who should you really be loyal to? A guy caught in the middle of that problem in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，如果你的国家被外国军队占领了，而你为那支军队工作。你到底应该效忠于谁？一分钟后，一个陷入这个难题的人将告诉你答案。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续进行。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, By Proxy, stories of people substituting themselves for other people, and the difficulties that can create. We've arrived at act two of our show. Act two, Killing The Messengers. Being a proxy can get you murdered. Basim grew up in Iraq, trainined to be an English interpreter. And when the US Army arrived, he got a chance to try out his language skills on actual native English speakers for the first time in his life. Iraq had been cut off from the world for so long, he says, that generations of English teachers were not able to travel outside the country and speak English. So his English had all kinds of mistakes in it as a result.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题，并为你带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目主题是“代理人”，讲述人们代替他人行事的故事，以及由此产生的困境。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“杀死信使”。成为代理人可能会让你送命。巴辛在伊拉克长大，受训成为英语口译员。当美军到达时，他第一次有机会在现实中对真正的英语母语者尝试运用他的语言技能。他说，伊拉克与世界隔绝太久了，几代英语老师都无法出国说英语。结果，他的英语犯了各种各样的错误。
But he spoke well enough that the Americans offered him a job as an interpreter, and it was a job that he really loved. He made decent money, and he felt like he was helping rebuild his country and bring it into the modern world. But translating for the US Army meant being a proxy for the Americans when he was talking to Iraqis, and being a proxy for the Iraqis when he was talking to American soldiers, which put him in a lot of tough situations.
但他英语说得足够好，美国人雇佣他做了翻译，他非常热爱这份工作。他赚了不少钱，觉得自己在帮助重建国家，并将它带入现代世界。但为美军翻译意味着在与伊拉克人交谈时他是美国人的代理人，而在与美国士兵交谈时他是伊拉克人的代理人，这使他陷入了许多艰难的境地。
A quick example: sometimes Iraqi policemen and police trainees would be standing right next to the Americans and then bad mouth them in Arabic. Basim wouldn't translate what they said. That would just make trouble. Instead, he would warn the police in Arabic that they should watch their mouths. That some translators would, in fact, tell the Americans what they were saying word for word, and there was no predicting how the Americans would react. Sometimes the Iraqi police would reply that Basim was taking the Americans' side. It was their country.
举个例子：有时伊拉克警察和警员受训者会站在美国人旁边用阿拉伯语说他们的坏话。巴辛不会翻译他们所说的话。那只会引起麻烦。相反，他会用阿拉伯语警告警察注意言辞。他说有些翻译确实会逐字逐句告诉美国人他们说了什么，而美国人的反应是无法预测的。有时伊拉克警察会回答说巴辛站在美国人那边。那是他们的国家。
And we are talking about Iraqi policemen. They were an authority in Iraq. And it's hard to be in the middle between American soldiers-- I don't want to say that American soldiers are arrogant or something like that, but it is an army kind of life. And those policemen are being very sensitive, because, well, their country is occupied, their army is being defeated. And now, they have to receive orders and instructions from their former enemy. So you have to be very sensitive in order to create a kind of, let's say, a friendship, a kind of common understanding between the two parties.
我们在谈论伊拉克警察。他们曾是伊拉克的权威。夹在美国士兵——我不想说美国士兵傲慢之类的——之间很难受，但那是一种军队生活。而那些警察非常敏感，因为，嗯，他们的国家被占领了，他们的军队被击败了。现在，他们必须接受前敌人的命令和指示。所以你必须非常敏感，才能在双方之间建立一种——我们可以说是友谊，一种共同理解。
And so give me an example of an order the way the Americans would say it, and what you would have to do to it in order to get it across.
那么请给我举一个美国人下达命令的例子，以及你为了让对方接受必须如何转换它。
Yeah, like for example, I used to have a boss who is a lieutenant colonel in the American Army, who was very keen on the hygiene of Iraqi policemen, or on the cleanness of their police station. And we are in Iraq, we have the tradition to smoke everywhere. We can smoke in any place we want. And that Army commander was very keen on seeing Iraqi policemen, for example, throwing the butts of their cigarettes on the ground. And he used to follow them one by one, telling them to pick the cigarettes butts up from the ground and put it in an ashtray, or in a trash basket where it belongs.
是的，比如我以前有个老板是美军中校，他非常关注伊拉克警察的卫生，或者警察局的清洁程度。我们在伊拉克，我们有到处吸烟的传统。我们可以在任何想吸烟的地方吸烟。那位陆军指挥官非常反感看到伊拉克警察随地扔烟头。他总是跟着他们一个接一个地告诉他们把烟头从地上捡起来扔进烟灰缸，或者扔进属于它的垃圾桶。
And sometimes, a form of military order like that would be interpreted in a bad way, like the Iraqi policemen would think, OK, this is my police station, this is my country. I can do whatever I want. I can throw my cigarette butt whenever I want, or wherever I want. So when you interpret a situation like that, where you have an American commander telling an Iraqi policeman, hey, don't just throw the butt of your cigarette on the ground, it would have to be interpreted in another way, like, well, do you think that somebody is going to come and clean that after you? So please be very kind, and when you smoke, please be aware that you have to throw your cigarette butt in a place where it reflects a good image of your police station. You don't want the Americans to think that you are dirty or something. And this is how we interpret situations.
有时，这种军事命令会被解读为错误的方式，比如伊拉克警察会认为：好吧，这是我的警察局，这是我的国家。我想做什么就做什么。我想随手扔烟头就扔在哪儿。所以当你解读这种情况时，比如有个美国指挥官告诉伊拉克警察，“嘿，别把烟头扔在地上”，你必须以另一种方式解读，比如，“好吧，你觉得会有人来帮你清理吗？所以请行行好，当你吸烟时，请注意你必须把烟头扔在能体现警察局良好形象的地方。你不想让美国人认为你们很脏什么的。”这就是我们解读情况的方式。
Basim, why not just turn to the Americans and say, well let these men be. This is our culture here, we throw the cigarettes. What difference does it make?
巴辛，为什么不直接对美国人说，“好吧，让他们这样吧。这是我们的文化，我们随手扔烟头。那有什么区别呢？”
Well, because I have this kind of belief that if we listen to those people, to the Americans, things would be better for us. We need this kind of education. And it starts from small things, and it grows up to the big things. If the American soldier or commander have the time to teach you where to throw your cigarette, then he would be teaching you how to treat your prisoners. He would be teaching you how to have like a professional ethics. He would be teaching you how to do much more important things.
嗯，因为我有一种信念：如果我们听从这些人，听从美国人的话，对我们会更好。我们需要这种教育。这从小事开始，然后延伸到大事。如果美国士兵或指挥官有时间教你在哪儿扔烟头，那么他也会教你如何对待囚犯。他会教你如何具备专业道德。他会教你如何去做更重要的事情。
And also you're working for him. It's your job to say what he wants you to say.
而且你是在为他工作。说出他想让你说的话是你的工作。
And this is one part of the story, yeah.
这也是故事的一部分，是的。
The more you tell these stories, the more it's clear that your job is so much more than translating the words.
你讲的故事越多，就越清楚你的工作远不止翻译字面意思那么简单。
There is a situation where I was with a new boss. We have received somebody who is a Major in the army who was in charge of our unit, and I had to lie to him in one incident. Because we went to the City Hall in the city of Mosul, trying to do some security assessment of the building itself. And there were about 150 or more Iraqi protesters who are protesting against the Americans at that point. And our new commander has said, well, we have to do it no matter what. We have to do that assessment today. And I told him, but there are protesters who can be provoked by our existence, like we with our Humvees and with our weapons and stuff like that. And he said, no, it doesn't matter.
有一个情况是我和一位新上司在一起。我们接待了一位负责我们部队的陆军少校，有一次我不得不对他撒谎。因为我们去了摩苏尔市政府大楼，试图对大楼本身进行安全评估。当时大约有150名或更多的伊拉克抗议者正在抗议美国人。我们的新指挥官说，好吧，无论如何我们都要做。我们今天一定要做评估。我告诉他，但那里有抗议者，我们的出现——带着悍马车、武器之类的——会激怒他们。他说，不，没关系。
And I was talking to an Iraqi policeman who said, well, you can do the assessment now-- he's a high ranking officer in the police-- and we can manage with the protester if they got any kind of action, or if they start to throw stones or something like that. And the way I translated it to the American officer, I told him that the Iraqi officer was saying that we should leave right now, because we don't want to provoke the protesters, we don't want to use their weapons against them today. And the American officer thought about it and said, yeah, let's do the assessment another day.
当时我正在和一个伊拉克警察谈话，他说——他是警察中的一名高级官员——“好吧，你们现在可以进行评估，如果抗议者有任何行动，或者如果他们开始扔石头之类的，我们可以应付。”但我向美国军官翻译时，我告诉他伊拉克官员的意思是“我们现在应该离开，因为我们不想激怒抗议者，我们今天不想动用他们的武器对付他们。”美国军官思考了一下说，“是的，我们改天再做评估。”
In a situation like that, the Iraqi officer did not have the right judgment about the situation, because those protesters were very angry. And the American officer has his schedule, has his plan, he wants to do the building security assessment. But I was the only one who can see a group of Iraqi people who were angry, and who can start throwing stones, and somebody can get in the middle of them with a weapon or with a rifle and start shooting, and the Americans and the Iraqi police will shoot back, and there will be casualties, which is something that can be avoided. In a situation like that, I thought this is the only lie that I felt very comfortable about.
在这种情况下，伊拉克官员对局势的判断是不对的，因为那些抗议者非常愤怒。而美国军官有他的时间表，有他的计划，他想进行建筑安全评估。但我是一个人，我看到了那群愤怒的伊拉克人，他们随时可能开始扔石头，而有人可能带着武器或步枪介入其中并开始射击，美国人和伊拉克警察会回击，就会造成本可以避免的伤亡。在这种情况下，我认为这是我唯一感到非常心安理得的谎言。
When you study to be an interpreter, did they tell you to be completely neutral?
当你学习当翻译时，他们告诉你要完全中立吗？
Yes. I know that. But we have not received any kind of study, any kind of academic study on how to be translators in a war situation, in a battlefield, if you know what I mean.
是的。我知道。但我们没有接受过任何学术训练，关于在战争情况、战场上如何做翻译，如果你明白我的意思的话。
I know. What's interesting about these examples is that it's not just that you're just interpreting what's going on, but in a sense, you're taking over for whoever's in charge. Do you know what I mean? With the protesters, you're saying that you know better what's going to get everyone through the situation, and you're actually taking over.
我明白。这些例子有趣的地方在于，不仅仅是你翻译正在发生的事情，某种意义上，你是在代替负责任的人行事。你知道我的意思吗？关于抗议者，你说你知道什么能让大家平安度过，你实际上是在接管局面。
Yeah, because if something wrong happened, where the Americans whom I work with have to shoot some people who are demonstrating and people got killed, or other people got wounded, or an American friend of mine got killed or got wounded, I would never forgive myself because I didn't take an action, because I didn't took a stand. Because I have to do something. We have to avoid tension, if you know what I mean.
是的，因为如果发生了什么坏事，如果我一起工作的美国人不得不射杀一些示威者，导致人员死亡，或者是其他人受伤，或者我的一位美国朋友被杀或受伤，我永远不会原谅自己，因为我没有采取行动，没有表明立场。因为我必须做点什么。我们必须避免冲突，如果你明白我的意思。
The Army unit that Basim was working with trained Iraqi police. This meant that Basim spent a lot of time translating American police manuals into Arabic, and transiting lectures about police procedure. And as an Iraqi who had always been afraid of the police under Saddam, when police seemed able to do whatever it is that they wanted, Basim really liked this part of his job, teaching Iraqi police to work the way the police operate in modern countries, Western countries. On how to treat detainees, how to respect prisoners' human rights. How to stop a riot without brutality. How to exercise authority fairly, without taking bribes.
巴辛工作的陆军部队负责训练伊拉克警察。这意味着巴辛花了很多时间把美国警察手册翻译成阿拉伯语，翻译关于警察程序的讲座。作为在萨达姆统治下一直害怕警察——警察似乎随心所欲——的伊拉克人，巴辛真的很喜欢这份工作的这一部分，教伊拉克警察像现代国家、西方国家的警察一样运作。如何对待被拘留者，如何尊重囚犯的人权。如何在不使用暴力的情况下平息骚乱。如何公正地行使职权，而不收受贿赂。
And so in April, 2004, when photos from Abu Ghraib prison became public, it was especially disheartening to Basim. This is not what he believed the Americans were all about.
所以2004年4月，当阿布格莱布监狱的照片公开时，巴辛感到特别灰心。这与他所相信的美国人完全不同。
For me as a person, it was just like the shock of my lifetime, because it was the total opposite of what we were teaching the Iraqi prison guards on how to treat and deal with the prisoners. And that was the biggest thing that has turned most of the Iraqis against the Americans. Even those Iraqis who were somehow supporting the American were very afraid to show their support to the American. They couldn't show any kind of support to the American anymore.
对我个人而言，那简直是我一生中最大的震惊，因为它与我们教伊拉克狱警如何对待和处理囚犯的方式完全相反。那是导致大多数伊拉克人转而反对美国人的最大事件。即使是那些原本某种程度上支持美国人的伊拉克人，也害怕表现出他们的支持。他们再也无法表现出任何形式的支持了。
You mean after Abu Ghraib?
你是说阿布格莱布事件之后？
And here comes the loud voice of religious men and the tribal leaders in my city. They said that everything that the American has came with is just a lie, just like their democracy, just like their liberty, just like their freedom of speech. This is what they do to you if they arrest you, even if it was a wrongful arrest, or something like that. This is nothing that I was fighting for. This is not the thing that I was willing to see happening again in my country. We have seen and heard too many examples of torture, of abuse of prisoners in Saddam's time.
接着我所在城市的宗教人士和部落领袖发出了愤怒的声音。他们说美国人带来的一切都只是谎言，就像他们的民主、他们的自由、他们的言论自由一样。如果你被捕，即使是错误逮捕，这就是他们对你所做的事情。这不是我为之奋斗的东西。这不是我愿意在我的国家再次看到的事情。我们在萨达姆时代已经见过并听过太多关于折磨和虐待囚犯的例子。
During this period, it became much harder, Basim says, to convince Iraqis that the Americans were doing anything good.
巴辛说，在此期间，要让伊拉克人相信美国人在做任何好事变得困难多了。
The unit that I was working with was doing its best, but people were not receiving the message.
和我一起工作的部队在尽最大努力，但人们并没有收到这个信息。
Give me an example of the kind of thing that would happen in those months.
举个那几个月里会发生的例子。
For example, there were small kids who were just around the American convoys. Those kids, for example, sell CDs, like music CDs, movies to the American soldier. And he gives them candy, and he looks at the things that they are selling, and he tries to help them with $1 or $2. And the next day we hear the imams in the mosque saying that the Americans are distributing porn CDs to the young children who were always around their convoys. Which was really shocking for me because I was there, and I know exactly that the Americans would not do that and I have not seen any incident that the American would do that. Everything was received negatively, at least by the people in my town, in my city.
例如，有一些小孩总是围绕在美国车队周围。这些孩子会卖CD，比如音乐CD、电影CD给美国大兵。士兵会给他们糖果，看他们卖的东西，并试图用一两美元帮助他们。第二天我们就听到清真寺里的伊玛目说，美国人正在向围绕在他们车队周围的年幼儿童分发色情CD。这让我非常震惊，因为我在现场，我非常清楚美国人绝不会那样做，我也没有见过任何美国人会那样做的事情。一切都被负面地解读了，至少我镇上、我城市里的人是这么想的。
Before long, it became dangerous to be a translator. Early in the occupation, clerics had issued an official statement saying it was OK for Iraqis to work with the Americans, including translators. But a year into the occupation, the mood in the country had changed. Translator friends of Basim's were getting killed. One of his teachers, an assistant professor who trained English interpreters at the University of Mosul was killed by people who said that she was graduating traitors.
没过多久，做翻译变得危险了。占领初期，教士们发布了一份官方声明，说伊拉克人可以为美国人工作，包括翻译。但占领一年后，国内的气氛变了。巴辛的翻译朋友们开始被杀。他的一位老师，曾在摩苏尔大学培训英语口译员的助理教授被那些声称她正在培养叛徒的人杀害了。
One day Basim's unit was supposed to process and release a bunch of prisoners who had been transported from Abu Ghraib. Men, they were told, who had been investigated by the Americans and found to have done nothing wrong.
一天，巴辛的部队要处理并释放一批从阿布格莱布监狱转移出来的囚犯。他们被告知，这些人已经经过美国人的调查，确认没做任何错事。
So one of those prisoners who were about to be released after spending six months in Abu Ghraib prison. He said, we will kill you one by one. And I asked him, who do you mean by killing one by one? The Americans or us, the policemen or the translator? He said, no, you. And for me, I thought, well, this is a man who is totally angry for being in a prison for six months, and who has maybe been treated badly and I measure it out and say that this is an angry man. He would not be killing anybody after he was released. So things like that, those things that I will not be translating, for example. I don't know if I committed a mistake or not.
其中一个被关了六个月后即将释放的囚犯说：“我们会一个接一个地杀了你们。”我问他：“你说的‘一个接一个杀了你们’是指谁？美国人，还是我们，警察或者是翻译？”他说：“不，是你。”对我来说，我当时想，好吧，这是一个在监狱里待了六个月，非常愤怒，可能受到过虐待的人，我衡量了一下认为他只是一个愤怒的人。他被释放后不会去杀任何人。所以类似的事情，我不会去翻译。我不知道我是否犯了错误。
You wouldn't tell the Americans he said that he's going to kill you?
你没有告诉美国人他说他要杀了你？
No, I didn't tell them.
不，我没告诉他们。
Because you just assumed, well, they will just throw him back in prison?
因为你假设他们会直接把他扔回监狱？
Yeah, because I don't like to have anybody, because of me, get back to prison or receive any bad treatment, especially if he was Iraqi.
是的，因为我不喜欢任何人因为我而被关回监狱或受到任何恶劣对待，尤其是如果他是伊拉克人的话。
Was it frightening?
当时害怕吗？
Well, I was not frightened, I was surrounded by like 20 American soldiers or something like that. But after I left, and I sat back home with my wife, and I told her, and she said something that made me really frightened, saying that those people, especially those who've been in the prison and who have received bad treatment, will not sit down and feel very happy about they are being released. They will come back trying to get revenge, not necessarily from the Americans but from anybody who they suspect has participated in putting them into prison.
嗯，我不害怕，我被大约20个美国士兵保护着。但离开后，我回到家里和妻子坐在一起，我告诉了她，她说出的一番话让我感到非常害怕。她说，那些人，尤其是那些在监狱里受过虐待的人，在被释放后绝不会坐着感到高兴。他们会回来寻求报复，不一定是报复美国人，而是报复任何他们怀疑参与过把他们送进监狱的人。
And in that time especially, in early 2004, the word translator itself has became a taboo in Iraqi society. It has became a very scary word, like Sunni religious authorities have suddenly decided that everybody who's working for the Americans is-- forgive me for saying this-- is worse than the Americans themselves. If you have the chance to kill a translator or American, kill the translator first.
而在那个时候，特别是在2004年初，“翻译”这个词在伊拉克社会已经成了禁忌。它成了一个非常可怕的词，就像逊尼派宗教权威突然决定，每一个为美国人工作的人——请原谅我这么说——都比美国人自己还糟糕。如果你有机会杀一个翻译或一个美国人，先杀翻译。
That's such a shocking thing. What did you think? Do you remember where you were standing? What did you think when you heard that?
那太令人震惊了。你怎么想？你还记得当时站在哪里吗？当你听到这些时，你心里怎么想？
The feeling wasn't great, because you're just in the middle of 27 million, most of them thinking that killing you would be better than killing the Americans. So it is just one of those feelings that make you really, really scared. You might not imagine that, or maybe your audience might not imagine that, but speaking English-- like you're walking down the street with your friends, and it came up to your mind that now you are going to speak an English word, this is at some point in Iraq, especially in 2005, 2006, has become enough reason for somebody who do that to get killed. Speaking one word or two words in English in the street, or in the market, or in front of anybody else, would be enough reason for you to get assassinated.
感觉糟透了，因为你身处于2700万人之中，其中大多数人认为杀了你比杀美国人更好。所以这真是一种让你感到非常、非常害怕的感觉。你可能无法想象，或者你的听众可能无法想象，但说英语——就像你和朋友走在街上，想到现在你要说一句英语，在伊拉克某些时刻，尤其是2005年、2006年，这就成了让人送命的理由。在街上、市场上或任何人面前说一两个英语单词，就足以让你被暗杀。
A few weeks after the prisoner said that he was going to kill Basim, Basim got a threatening phone call. And then a package arrived.
在那个囚犯威胁要杀巴辛的几周后，巴辛接到了一通威胁电话。然后一个包裹到了。
It was a message printed by a typical printer, by computer. The beginning was some verses of Ram Koran. Then there is this message to me with my full name on it, saying that we have recognized you and identified you as an infidel and a traitor, and a helper of the infidels. And if you don't quit your job at once, you would be killed with all your family. And that was serious because there was a CD disc, a disc, a compact disc with the message, showing the beheading of a friend of mine. Well, he's a colleague more than a friend.
那是一条用典型的打印机打印出的信息。开头是一些《古兰经》的经文。接着是写给我的信息，上面有我的全名，说我们已经认出你并确定你是异教徒和叛徒，是异教徒的帮凶。如果你不立即辞职，你和你的全家都会被杀。那是严肃的，因为里面有一个CD光盘，一张光盘，上面有视频，展示了我一位朋友被斩首的画面。好吧，他与其说是朋友，不如说是同事。
Another translator?
另一个翻译？
Another translator, of course. He's a Christian.
当然是另一个翻译。他是个基督徒。
When you get a DVD like that, did you watch the DVD?
当你收到那样的光盘时，你看过吗？
I watched the first part of it before the beheading started. And that feeling was just indescribable because it is the most scary feeling ever. Seeing it happen to somebody that you know, somebody that you have talked to, somebody that you had conversation with is the most painful part of it, because those monsters were treating him very bad. They knew that they will behead him in minutes, but it was full of insults, and full of bad words. They beated him, they spoke to him very badly.
我在斩首开始前看了第一部分。那种感觉简直无法用语言形容，因为这是有史以来最可怕的感觉。看着它发生在你认识的人、你交谈过的人、你曾经和他对话过的人身上，这是最痛苦的部分，因为那些怪物对他非常残酷。他们知道几分钟后就会斩首他，但全程充满了侮辱和恶毒的话语。他们殴打他，言语极其恶毒。
Did he speak in the video?
他在视频里说话了吗？
Well, he spoke his name in a very low voice, because I think his teeth were broken or something. He spoke his name, and they asked him about the nature of his job, so he said, I'm a traitor. It seems like they told him to say so. I haven't finished the rest of the film but I guess you can find it on the internet if you look for it, because they have posted like tens and hundreds of those films.
嗯，他用非常低的声音说了自己的名字，因为我想他的牙齿被打断了什么的。他说出了自己的名字，他们问他关于他工作的性质，于是他说：“我是叛徒。”看起来他们逼他这么说的。我没看完剩下的部分，但如果你去搜的话，我想能在网上找到，因为他们已经发布了成百上千个这样的视频。
And so around this time, your family basically kicked you out of the house, right? They didn't want you there because it made things too dangerous for them.
大约在这个时候，你的家人基本上把你赶出了家门，对吧？他们不想让你呆在那儿，因为那对他们来说太危险了。
They kicked me out of the house. They told me, this is your choice. You are not young. You are an adult. And you don't want us to die because of a decision that you have taken. So it is not enough for you to quit your job now, it has become a necessity for you to disappear.
他们把我赶出了家门。他们对我说：“这是你的选择。你不是小孩子了。你是成年人。你不想让我们因为你做的决定而死。”所以现在仅仅辞职已经不够了，消失已经成了你的必需。
Basim went on the run. He hid in another town. But when his pregnant wife gave birth to their son, he drove back after curfew to reach her. A three hour drive in the dark past checkpoints where he had to guess if the checkpoints were Sunni or Shia. When they ask if you're Sunni or Shia, if you give the wrong answer, you're dead. Then he just hid for three months.
巴辛开始了逃亡。他躲在另一个城市。但当他怀孕的妻子生下儿子时，他在宵禁后开车回去找她。在黑暗中经过检查站行驶了三小时，他必须猜那是逊尼派还是什叶派的检查站。如果他们问你是逊尼派还是什叶派，如果给错答案，你就死定了。然后他就躲藏了三个月。
Before all this running, he'd actually gone to the Americans to ask for help and for protection. The Americans offered to let him live on the Army base, though without his family. Or they said they would drive him home every night in a military convoy to his family's house.
在这一切逃亡之前，他其实已经去找过美国人请求帮助和保护。美国人提出让他住在陆军基地，尽管不能带上家人。或者他们说可以每天晚上用军事车队把他送回他家。
At that point I realized that the Americans-- most of them-- have not realized the nature of their enemy. It is not a good thing to be seen in an American convoy that drives you to your home. That will be the cause of the death of maybe my whole family and my neighbors too.
在那一刻我意识到，美国人——他们大多数人——还没意识到他们敌人的本质。被美军车队送回家绝不是什么好事。那将导致我的全家甚至邻居的死亡。
So in the end, you wanted to be a bridge between these two cultures, between the Americans and the Iraqis?
所以最终，你想成为这两种文化之间，美国人和伊拉克人之间的桥梁？
Yeah.
是的。
Was it naive to believe that someone could stand in the middle like that?
相信一个人能站在中间，这种想法是不是太天真了？
No, it wasn't at all. Because most of the misunderstandings, most of the problems that are happening now between the Americans and the normal Iraqi people are due to the lack of full understanding. And in order to achieve that level of full understanding between those totally different group of people, there should be somebody. Our job is building a bridge. If you are a translator, then you build a bridge.
不，一点也不。因为现在美国人和普通伊拉克人民之间发生的大多数误解、大多数问题，都是由于缺乏充分了解。为了在这些完全不同的人群之间实现那种程度的充分理解，必须得有桥梁。我们的工作就是架桥。如果你是翻译，你就是在架桥。
And I always say that if something happened, something wrong happened in the process of building that bridge, the first people who sink into the water are people who are on the bridge, trying to reach out for the other side. And we translators play that role, not only in this war, but in all the wars that happens around the world between nations with different languages. It always happens like that. If I move away, and anybody move away, this would be the best chance for the evil forces, for the terrorism, to control the country, and to cut the bridges that we were trying to build.
我常说，如果在这个架桥过程中出了问题，第一个沉进水里的人就是那些站在桥上、试图向另一边伸手的人。我们翻译就是扮演这个角色，不仅在这场战争中，而且在世界各地不同语言国家之间发生的所有战争中。总是这样。如果我离开，任何人离开，这对邪恶势力、恐怖主义来说将是控制国家、切断我们试图建立的桥梁的最佳机会。
In the end, Basim felt he had no choice. He left Iraq feeling like he should still be there. Today, Iraqis doing translation for the American forces are kind of an endangered species, a hunted species. The company that hired Basim to work for the Americans, Titan Corporation, has had 323 of its interpreters killed while on the job according to The Christian Science Monitor. But when the US Army relies on interpreters from outside Iraq, Basim says, they have trouble with Iraqi dialects, local meanings and customs. And they make all kinds of translating mistakes that no Iraqi would make.
最终，巴辛觉得自己别无选择。他离开伊拉克时觉得他本该呆在那儿。今天，为美军做翻译的伊拉克人是一种濒危物种，一种被猎杀的物种。据《基督教科学箴言报》报道，雇佣巴辛为美国人工作的泰坦公司已有323名口译员在工作中被杀。但巴辛说，当美军依赖来自伊拉克以外的翻译时，他们会遇到伊拉克方言、当地俚语和习俗的问题。他们会犯各种任何伊拉克人都不会犯的翻译错误。
Basim and his wife and his son are now in Europe, in a community where there are a number of Pakistani and Iranian and Iraqi exiles. Back in Iraq, he was constantly having to explain the Americans to people. But in Europe, he's trying very hard to avoid doing that. He specifically tries to avoid telling people that he was an interpreter for the United States in Iraq.
巴辛和他的妻子儿子现在在欧洲，生活在一个有许多巴基斯坦、伊朗和伊拉克流亡者的社区。在伊拉克时，他不断地向人们解释美国人。但在欧洲，他非常努力地避免这样做。他特意避免告诉人们他曾是美国在伊拉克的口译员。
It is not something to be ashamed of. It is not dangerous here to tell people that I was a translator. But it's just, I wanted to avoid any situation where I have to justify why did I did what I've done in Iraq. And I don't want to be asked by people, now you have been a friend with the American, why did they do that? Why did they do this? So I just don't want to put myself in a situation like that. I just decided that I'm not really with or against the American policy, or the things that the Americans are doing in Iraq. And I don't feel like I have to explain anything to anyone.
这不是什么可耻的事。在这里告诉别人我曾是翻译也不危险。但只是，我想避免任何需要证明我为什么要在伊拉克那样做的处境。我不想被人们问：“既然你曾是美国人的朋友，为什么他们那样做？为什么他们做这个？”所以我只是不想让自己陷入那种境地。我只是决定我既不支持也不反对美国政策，或者美国人在伊拉克做的事情。我觉得我没必要向任何人解释什么。
[MUSIC - "DON'T LET ME BE MISUNDERSTOOD" BY NINA SIMONE]
[音乐 - “别误解我” - 妮娜·西蒙]
Act three, Redemption By Proxy. When you get right down to it, a reputation is kind of a strange idea. It is this idea about you, about who you really are that is somehow connected to you, but that is utterly abstract at the same time. You can't touch it. You can't pin it down in any exact way, and it changes depending on what you do. Until the day you die, then your reputation is in the hands of whoever cares enough to step in as your proxy and take charge of the historical record and tell people who you really were. Eve Abrams has this story.
第三幕，“代理救赎”。追根究底，名声是一个奇怪的概念。这是一个关于你的想法，关于你到底是谁，它与你息息相关，但同时又完全抽象。你摸不着它。你无法确切地定义它，而且它会随着你的行为而改变。直到你死的那天，那时你的名声就掌握在那些足够关心你的人手中，他们会介入作为你的代理人，负责历史记录，告诉人们你到底是谁。伊芙·艾布拉姆斯带来了这个故事。
I taught elementary school for 10 years in New York City at this place called The Neighborhood School. It was one of those schools where students call teachers by their first names and where teachers really get to know their students well-- their families, their strengths, their dramas. But sometimes, one kid stands out. This is a story about one of those kids, and his friend, and his teacher. Sophia is the teacher, and also a friend of mine. Lily was our student years ago. She's 16 now. And Lily's classmate Robert was our student too, but he's dead, so I'll let Lily tell you about him.
我在纽约市的一所名为“邻里学校”的地方教了10年小学。那是学生叫老师名字、老师能真正深入了解学生的地方——了解他们的家庭、长处和烦恼。但有时，有一个孩子会脱颖而出。这是一个关于其中一个孩子，以及他的朋友和老师的故事。索菲亚是老师，也是我的朋友。莉莉多年前是我们的学生。她现在16岁。莉莉的同学罗伯特也是我们的学生，但他死了，所以我让莉莉告诉你关于他的事。
I really had a hard time telling people who had died for a while, because I didn't want to say friend, and I didn't want to say best friend, because that makes it seem like, my best friend. You know what I mean? Anyone can say that they were his best friend. I mean, he lived so close to me, so we'd hang out 24/7. We talked about everything. In our school, everyone was pretty quiet and good, and I don't know, to me, he just seemed like he was different, and he was fun, and everyone else was boring.
有一阵子我很难开口告诉别人他已经去世了，因为我不想说“朋友”，也不想说“最好的朋友”，因为那会让人觉得……像是“我最好的朋友”。你知道我的意思吗？谁都能说他们曾是他最好的朋友。我的意思是，他住得离我太近了，所以我们整天24小时都在一起玩。我们无话不谈。在我们学校，每个人都很安静乖巧，我不知道，对我来说，他就是与众不同，他很有趣，而其他人很无聊。
Teachers never liked him. He was probably a little bit rude. Like he didn't do his homework. That was like a big thing, because at The Neighborhood School, everyone was like, got to do your homework, got to do your homework, or you're not going to go out for recess and all this stuff. And whatever, he'd be like, never going out for recess because he never did his homework.
老师们从不喜欢他。他可能有点无礼。比如他不做作业。这在“邻里学校”是大忌，因为每个人都说：“必须做作业，必须做作业，否则你就不能去操场玩了，诸如此类。”管他呢，他会说：“从来不去操场”，因为他从来不做作业。
Robert didn't defer to adults and other kids were drawn to that. But he was also sort of hapless. He was the kind of kid who, when he cut school, got caught.
罗伯特从不顺从大人，其他孩子被这一点吸引。但他也很不幸。他是那种逃学时总会被抓到的孩子。
He got kicked out of middle school, which was always like really weird to me, because there were so many kids that were so much worse. There was kids that came in that school once a week at 10 o'clock, and like grabbed a girl and left.
他被初中开除了，这对我来说总是很奇怪，因为还有很多孩子比他糟糕得多。有些孩子一周只来一次，10点钟才到，强行拉走一个女孩就离开了。
I had a crush on him the second I saw him. Fifth grade was the big year that I really had a big crush on him. It was just like, oh my God, I love you. He one time left me flowers at my door-- it was my birthday-- and knocked on the door and ran away. And so I opened the door and there's flowers, and I was like, oh my God, he loves me, like flowers. And so I picked it up and there was a note, and it said: From Robert, To Lily, Happy Birthday. PS, don't get happy. Like, as in like, whatever, don't get happy, don't think I like you because I'm doing this. Don't get happy. I was like, but I am happy because you left me flowers.
我第一眼看到他就对他产生了好感。五年级是我真正深深迷恋他的那一年。那感觉就是：天哪，我爱你。有一次他把花留在我的门口——那天是我的生日——敲了敲门就跑开了。所以我打开门看到了花，我就想：天哪，他爱我，竟然送花！我拿起花，发现上面有一张便条，写着：“来自罗伯特，致莉莉，生日快乐。注：别高兴。”意思是，随便啦，别高兴，别以为我给你这个就是喜欢你。别高兴。我心想，但我就是因为你送我花而高兴啊。
I realized it's actually because I liked him so much as a friend, and I never really had somebody that was a boy that I liked so much as a friend. So I figured I must be in love with him or I must like have the big-- but it's also like I just actually always really liked him as a person.
我意识到这其实是因为我真的很喜欢他这个朋友，而且我从没遇到过像他这样如此喜欢的男性朋友。所以我心想我一定是爱上他了，或者是……但同时，我也确实一直很喜欢他这个人。
That's how Lily saw Robert. Sofia saw him differently. After he was in my class, Robert moved on to Sophia's class right next door, and a lot of times, I'd see and hear them out in the hall together. Mostly I'd hear Sofia. She would lecture Robert about homework and effort and attitude, and her voice got really loud and annoyed. While Sophia lectured, Robert just stood there.
莉莉就是这样看待罗伯特的。索菲亚则不同。他上完我的课后，罗伯特搬到了隔壁索菲亚的班级，很多次我都会看到并在走廊里听到他们在一起。大多时候我会听到索菲亚的声音。她会就作业、努力程度和态度向罗伯特说教，她的声音变得非常响亮和烦躁。当索菲亚说教时，罗伯特只是站在那里。
Rolling his eyes. I mean, it was more a physical manifestation, just kind of listening to me, but not really listening, kind of looking off in the distance. Head was at a tilt, arms crossed, kind of like waiting for the episode to end.
翻着白眼。我的意思是，那更像是一种肢体语言，虽然听着我在说，但并没有真正听进去，眼神望着远方。头歪着，双臂交叉，就像在等那一集结束。
Sophia had a harder time with Robert than I did. He was older by the time she taught him, but his reading wasn't much better, and he still struggled with his schoolwork. He'd also gotten really good at deflecting all of the things that teachers would try-- ordering, cajoling, tricking. Sofia would see Robert around the neighborhood after school, hanging out with older boys, doing nothing much. And it frustrated her to no end that this smart, charming kid seemed headed for a lifetime of dead end jobs and disappointments.
索菲亚教罗伯特比我更吃力。教他的时候他已经长大了，但他的阅读水平没好多少，仍然在学业上挣扎。他还变得非常擅长反击老师们尝试的一切——命令、哄劝、引诱。索菲亚放学后会在社区里看到罗伯特，和年纪较大的男孩在一起，无所事事。这个聪明、迷人的孩子似乎注定要过一辈子枯燥的低薪工作和失望的生活，这让她感到无比沮丧。
At one point, when I was kind of getting near the end of my rope, I talked to his family about making him stay after school in the classroom just so he can get his homework done. And I think we did it for like a week or two, and I don't think it was a very successful-- it wasn't a habit he could replicate at home.
有一次，当我快要忍无可忍的时候，我和他的家人谈过让他放学后留在教室里，这样他至少能完成作业。我想我们坚持了一两周，但我不觉得这很成功——这不是他能在家里养成的习惯。
Incidents between Sophia and Robert piled up and the year ended badly between them. Someone wrote an obscenity about Sofia on the school wall, up high where only a tall kid could write, and our principal was convinced it was Robert. He ended up being banned from the big end of the year party. When Robert didn't show up at graduation, other kids at the school, including Lily, blamed Sofia, even though Sophia had nothing to do with it. Not going had been Robert's decision.
索菲亚和罗伯特之间的冲突越来越多，那一年他们关系很糟糕。有人在学校墙上写了关于索菲亚的淫秽文字，写得很高，只有高个子的孩子才能写到，校长认定那人就是罗伯特。他最终被禁止参加大型毕业派对。当罗伯特没去参加毕业典礼时，学校里的其他孩子，包括莉莉，都怪罪索菲亚，尽管索菲亚对此一无所知。没去那是罗伯特的决定。
Mostly, Sophia felt she'd done the best that she could with Robert, but she wasn't sure. She felt bad when she thought about him-- bad for not reaching him, bad for having been hard on him. And for the next few years, she dreaded seeing Robert around the neighborhood, especially with other kids she knew, like Lily.
总的来说，索菲亚觉得她已经尽了最大的努力，但她不确定。想到他时，她感到很难过——为没能感化他而难过，为对他太严厉而难过。在接下来的几年里，她害怕在社区看到罗伯特，尤其是当他和其他她认识的孩子（比如莉莉）在一起时。
And then one day Sophia heard Robert was dead, stabbed to death for reasons no one knows, even today. He had just turned 16 two weeks before.
然后有一天索菲亚听说罗伯特死了，被捅死，原因至今无人知晓。他在两周前刚满16岁。
After Robert was killed, I had this nightmare. I dreamed that two or three of the girls in that class were really upset with me, and they were talking about the time when I had asked Robert to stay after school and work on his homework. One of the girls had accused me of preventing him from joining a basketball league. And she said that because I didn't let him do that, because I made him stay after school to work on his homework, he didn't get a chance to make better friends, and do something that was better for him and more productive. And it really felt like maybe they have something there.
罗伯特被杀后，我做了个噩梦。梦到那个班里的两三个女孩对我非常不满，她们一直在说我曾经让罗伯特放学后留下来写作业的事。其中一个女孩指责我阻止他参加篮球队。她说因为我不让他参加，因为我强迫他放学后留下来写作业，他失去了结交更好朋友的机会，没能做一些对他更好、更有意义的事。感觉她们说得确实有道理。
If nothing else had happened, Robert would have stayed like that in Sophia's head for years-- a kid she always had regrets about, always wished she'd done a better job with. But about six weeks after Robert died, Lily came back to her old elementary school and showed up in Sophia's classroom out of the blue, and she did something none of our students had ever done.
如果没有后来的事，罗伯特在索菲亚心中就会一直维持那个样子——一个她总感到遗憾的孩子，一个她总是希望当初能做得更好的孩子。但在罗伯特去世六周后，莉莉回到了她的小学，突然出现在索菲亚的教室里，她做了我们学生中从来没人做过的事。
I was surprised to see her, of all people, in my room, in my class, visiting me. And then she said, I wanted to give you this, and she handed me a note that she'd written, and then she left. And then when I read the note, I couldn't believe-- I just couldn't leave. I had to read the letter over again. I keep it in my wallet. I wanted to frame it. But sometimes I feel like I just need to read that letter again, just to remind me.
我很惊讶看到她，竟然是她，出现在我的教室里探望我。然后她说：“我想给你这个”，她递给我一张她写的便条，然后就离开了。读完那张便条后，我不敢相信……我读了又读。我把它放在钱包里。我想把它裱起来。但有时我觉得我需要再读一遍那封信，只是为了提醒自己。
Would you mind getting it now?
你介意现在拿出来读一下吗？
Sure, I'll read it. Dear Sophia, this is a letter of appreciation to you from me and Rob. Thank you very much for coming to Rob's wake. I know it would have meant so much to him to see how many people showed up. In the past three years, well, four years since me and Rob left The Neighborhood School, we have been best friends together every day.
当然，我读一下。“亲爱的索菲亚，这是一封我和罗布给你的感谢信。非常感谢你来参加罗布的葬礼。我知道看到这么多人到场，对他来说意义重大。在过去三年里，准确说是罗布和我不上‘邻里学校’后的四年里，我们每天都是最好的朋友。”
I just wanted to let you know how much Rob appreciated what you did for him as a teacher. Whenever we would talk about the past, he said that he understood everything you did for him, and that he was grateful for it. He showed me that people care for you, that's why sometimes they are harsh. For that reason, I thank you for teaching it to him. Rob always liked when people showed him they cared. He cared for you very much. Hope to see you soon, Lilly Torres.
“我只是想让你知道，罗布有多么感激你作为老师为他所做的一切。每当我们谈起过去，他说他理解你为他做的一切，并为此感到感激。他告诉我，人们关心你，所以有时才会严厉。因此，我感谢你教他这个道理。罗布总是喜欢人们向他展示关爱。他非常关心你。希望早日相见，莉莉·托雷斯。”
Lily wrote the note to Sophia on an impulse while she was grieving. She wasn't sure if it was the right thing to do, or if it was weird, or even if Robert would approve. But before she could talk herself out of it, she sat down at her kitchen counter and wrote it on a pink PostIt.
莉莉是在悲伤中凭直觉给索菲亚写了那张便条。她不确定这样做是否正确，是否显得怪异，甚至不确定罗伯特是否会赞同。但在她改变主意之前，她坐在厨房柜台边，在一张粉色便签纸上写下了它。
I think the thing is I really wanted people to know that he was a really great person. I mean, teachers were just always not liking him. And I just maybe thought maybe even if one teacher that he had knew that he liked them, or that-- not to change his reputation with every teacher that he ever had, but I was just trying to take a little bit of the bad off of his name, because I don't think he really deserved any bad at all.
我想我想说的是，我真的想让人们知道他是一个很棒的人。我的意思是，老师们总是因为他不听话而不喜欢他。我只是想，哪怕只有一位老师知道他其实很喜欢他们，或者……不是为了改变他在所有教过他的老师心目中的形象，但我只是想帮他洗刷一点点恶名，因为我觉得他根本不该被那样对待。
He was so mature about that whole thing about her and I wasn't at all. I thought maybe by showing her that, that she would know that he actually turned out pretty well. He said, I'm not mad, because I think that she was trying to do the best thing that she could for me, because we are talking about Sophia. I was just kind of like, she didn't how to handle you. And he was like, what are you talking about, she didn't know how to handle me? I was bad and she was just trying to help me. And he said that he was thankful that she took the time out to even care about him, even if it was yelling, or whatever it was, he said that it showed him that she cared.
他比我成熟得多，关于她和我的那整件事。我当时一点也不成熟。我心想也许通过向她展示这一点，她会知道他其实最后变成了个不错的人。他说：“我不生气，因为我觉得她当时是在尽全力帮我。”我是指关于索菲亚的事。我当时说：“她不知道该怎么处理你。”他说：“你在说什么？她不知道怎么处理我？我是个坏学生，她只是在试图帮我。”他说他很感激她花时间去关心他，即使那是大喊大叫，不管那是什么，他说这让他知道她是关心的。
Sophia never wrote back to Lily. She'd wanted to find the perfect way to thank her, but she couldn't decide what to say. And then she figured too much time had passed. Though Lily doesn't see it that way.
索菲亚从没回信给莉莉。她一直想找到一个完美的方式来感谢她，但她拿不定主意该说什么。然后她觉得时间过得太久了。尽管莉莉不这么想。
It's fine if she doesn't write me back. Or if she does, I don't think it's ever too late. You just never know what people need to know.
如果她不回信也没关系。或者如果她回了，我觉得永远都不算太晚。你永远不知道人们需要知道什么。
Until I spoke to her, Lily had no idea how much her note had meant to Sophia. That Sophia kept the note in her wallet, that it had lifted away years of guilt. For Lily, the note was about saving Robert, the part of him that was left in the world. She hadn't realized that it would also rescue Sophia.
直到我和她谈过，莉莉才知道那张便条对索菲亚意义重大。索菲亚把便条放在钱包里，它消除了她多年的负罪感。对莉莉来说，这张便条是为了拯救罗伯特，拯救他留在世上的那部分。她没意识到它同时拯救了索菲亚。
Eve Abrams, in New York.
纽约的伊芙·艾布拉姆斯。
Well, our program was produced today by Lisa Pollack and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind, Tommy Andres, PJ Vogt, and Emily Yousef. Music help from Jessica Hopper. Special thanks today to Dan Ephron, Sean Cullen, Dan Calhoun.
我们的节目今天由丽莎·波拉克和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维兹管理我们的网站。制作助理：塞斯·林德、汤米·安德烈斯、PJ·沃格特和艾米丽·优素福。音乐指导：杰西卡·霍珀。特别感谢丹·埃弗伦、肖恩·卡伦、丹·卡尔霍恩。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Support for This American Life is provided by Saab, founded by 16 Swedish aircraft engineers who decided to bring the spirit of flight down to Earth. Saab, born from jets. Learn more at saabusa.com.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。《美国生活》的支持由萨博汽车提供，该公司由16位瑞典飞机工程师创立，他们决定将飞行的精神带回地面。萨博，源于喷气机。了解更多请访问 saabusa.com。
Support for PRI comes from PBS, featuring their new series inspired by Car Talk, Click and Clack's As The Wrench Turns , premiering Wednesday night on most PBS stations.
PRI 的支持来自 PBS，他们推出了受《汽车谈话》启发的新系列《Click and Clack 的扳手转动》，周三晚上在大多数 PBS 频道首播。
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I tried to bring to him to my weekly basketball game. I tried, I tried, but it just didn't work out.
WBEZ 对本节目的管理监督由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责。你知道吗，我试过带他参加我的每周篮球比赛。我试过了，但我试过了，就是不行。
He didn't understand that he couldn't come out on the court when the grownups were playing, and I had to leave the game and take him home.
他不明白当大人们在比赛时他不能上场，我不得不中止比赛带他回家。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。